[Music]
it starts with a cough
or a wheeze soon your chest feels tight
your breathing speeds up and gets
shallower making you feel
short of breath these are common
symptoms of an
asthma attack around the world more than
300 million people suffer from asthma
and around 250 000 people die from it
each year but why do people get asthma
and how can this disease be deadly
asthma affects the respiratory system
particularly the smaller airways
such as the bronchi and bronchioles
these airways have an inner lining
called the mucosa that's surrounded by a
layer of smooth muscle
in people with asthma the airways are
chronically inflamed
which can make them hyper responsive to
certain triggers
some of the many asthma triggers include
tobacco smoke
pollen dust fragrances exercise
cold weather stress and even the common
cold
when people with asthma are exposed to
these triggers
an asthma attack or exacerbation can
occur
but how exactly do such everyday factors
lead to an asthma attack
if an asthmatic is exposed to a trigger
the smooth rings of muscle
that circle the small airways in their
lungs contract and become narrow
simultaneously the trigger worsens
inflammation
causing the mucosal lining to become
more swollen and secrete
more mucus under normal conditions
the body uses this mucus to trap and
clear particles
like pollen or dust but during an asthma
attack
it blocks the narrowed airways making it
even harder to breathe
these effects lead to the symptoms of
asthma
smooth muscle constriction results in
the feeling of chest
tightness excess mucus and increased
inflammation
can cause coughing and the wheezing
noise that happens because as the
airways constrict
air whistles as it passes through the
narrowed space
these symptoms may make a person feel
like they're running out of air
yet counter-intuitively during an asthma
attack the inflammation can make it
harder to exhale
than inhale over time this leads to an
excess of air in the lungs a phenomenon
known as hyperinflation
the trapping of air inside the lungs
forces the body to work harder
to move air in and out of them over time
this can lead to reduced oxygen delivery
to the body's organs and tissues
in untreated severe asthma attacks the
body can't keep up
which can lead to death from lack of
oxygen
so how do we prevent these uncomfortable
and potentially fatal attacks in people
who have asthma
one way is to reduce the presence of
triggers
unfortunately the world is an
unpredictable place and exposure to
triggers can't always be controlled
this is where inhalers the primary
treatment for asthma
come in these medications help
asthmatics both control
and prevent their asthma symptoms
inhalers transport medication
along the affected airways using a
liquid mist or fine
powder to treat the problem at its
source
they come in two forms there are
reliever medications
which treat symptoms immediately and
contain beta
agonists beta agonists relax constricted
muscles
allowing the airways to widen so more
air can travel into
and out of the lungs the other form of
inhalers
serve as preventive medications which
treat asthma symptoms over the long term
and contain corticosteroids
corticosteroids
reduce airway sensitivity and
inflammation so asthma can be kept under
control
they're also crucial in preventing
long-term damage from chronic
inflammation
which can cause scarring of the airways
inhalers are known to be very effective
and have helped many people live better
lives
although we've come a long way in
improving how we treat and
diagnose asthma we still don't know its
exact causes
we currently believe that a combination
of genetic and environmental factors
play a role
potentially acting during early
childhood
recent research has even linked poverty
to asthma incidents
this may be due to reasons ranging from
exposure to additional pollutants
and environmental irritants to
difficulties in obtaining medical care
or treatment
as our understanding of asthma improves
we can continue to find better ways to
keep people's airways
happy and healthy
[Music]
you